I was with a girl the other night and uh
I was by the commi store I was looking
for parking and one lot I go to the one
I always go to it was full I was like
all I'll just go another lot go to a
second lot right by the the pink dot I
go and the guy's like oh we're full and
I'm like two lots I'm 0 for two and I'm
I'm like what this girl she's super nice
I'm like dude this is if I was a girl
I'd be like one more lot I'm not blowing
this man I go to a third lot and they're
full I literally had to pay the guy
Saddle Ranch extra to be like can I park
here and go to The Comedy Store but I
was like 0 for three on lots and I was
like imagine being a girl in that seat
and you're like this guy can't even Park
a Tesla I am blowing his roommate so
quick I actually think that it's more
the way the guy talks to the parking lot
attendant if you're like hey chief I'm
like Chief's crazy Chief's crazy out the
gate I will really like a guy and'll
like what's up boss I'm like he's a
valet you know that he's no one's boss